picture is taken two weeks after 9 11.  while I'm working at Morgan Stanley Dean  weather  while Morgan Stanley lost 3 600  employees in their headquarters at World  Trade Center while A Man Named Dave  Kirby sadistan who was the general  manager branch manager of this place in  Glendale California and he said if you  guys left the industry today I would  fully understand it it's going to be  very very hard the next two years  think about a motivational speaker  giving you a message like that and it's  your boss  he sits us down vividly he says guys  if you chose to leave I fully get it the  next two year is going to be very hard  but I want to tell you something here  what's that if you do stick around and  you're in it after the two years  the kind of money some of you guys are  going to make none of us have ever made  before